there are so many antagonists in the
dark continent saga beyond netro the
karkin princes the mafia factions the
phantom troop hisoka and even the dark
continent itself and yet none of them
strike me with more fear than paristan
hill harriston is just built different
built wrong i should say and jing has
decided to push this monster to his very
limits hello and welcome to the new
world review your source for absurdly
well-dressed rat men my name is liam and
i have a button perhaps you would like
to push it but this video is part i mean
i've lost count of a recap series
designed to prepare you for the imminent
return of hunter hunter and whilst there
are any number of large-scale conflicts
currently happening there is nothing
more unsettling than pariston hill also
this video is sponsored by bloodline
heroes of lithus a card-based fantasy
rpg where you can not only collect
champions but also craft your own
legendary heirs by combining the
bloodlines of orcs likens demons and
even funky dragonborn and whilst i do
enjoy many of those things what i love
about this game is the art style and the
unique gacha gameplay choose your path
by raising heirs mixing bloodlines and
finding unique and endless combinations
of five powerful abilities to suit your
own specific style of gameplay and in
terms of characters i'm a big fan of the
cog dragonborn and they're very bold
handsome style although the lykans are
also pretty damn awesome and have great
designs plus you can also choose
demigods as companions and raise
extraordinarily powerful half demigods
so like a demi demigod but hey i still
think you're doing pretty well if you're
composed of any percent god so
bloodline heroes of lithus is available
for both android and ios plus you can
use my link in the description or scan
the qr code and you'll be granted a
random bloodline plus one champion token
100 000 gold and 100 diamonds so do that
thing but for now it's back to you me
like most unrest our story here begins
with the results of an election the
chairman election in this case which was
an absolute mess after pulling their
various mental and political strings the
battle between jing and paristan ended
in the political equivalent of erectile
dysfunction jing failed to prevent
paristan from becoming the next chairman
but pariston failed paristan and
resigned from the chairman position
roughly 20 seconds after he was crowned
this was a maneuver that confused
everyone whether they were characters in
hunter hunter or readers of the hunter
hunter manga however his reasoning would
become very clear in the next dark for
now after this bout of shenanigans both
jing and paristan resigned from the
zodiacs leaving cheadle as the default
chairman and in charge of cleaning up
their various messes now with jing you
could say that his reasons for leaving
are fairly simple because jing is quite
seasoned at abandoning his various
responsibilities whether they be
children or integral global political
infrastructure it doesn't really matter
because jing's law states that if he can
abandon something he will however
paristan he is a different nest of rats
altogether during his conversation with
cheadle pariston implies that his
actions during the election were one
last attempt at foiling the plans of
isaac network and that without netro to
play with the association had become a
rather boring place and it's not so much
that paristan is lying here he isn't but
he's presenting he's presenting a false
truth if that makes sense because
paristan's true reason for leaving was
because he'd been working with beyond
netro this entire time and i'd like to
take a moment to dwell on that at the
hunter association pariston served as
vice chairman to isaac netro but in
reality he was serving a second in
command to beyond netera this dude just
loves screwing over every netro he can
get his rat hands on but this makes
everything so much clearer for the
longest time paristan's purpose at the
hunter association had been a complete
mystery he presented himself as an
almost joker-like entity who existed
just to see the world burn and while
that still may be true it is highly
likely that paristan's purpose within
the hunter association was either to
kill or orchestrate the death of isaac
netara because isaac forbade his son
beyond from travelling to the dark
continent until after his death and
paristan whilst he was never seen did
actually play a huge role in the chimera
ant arc mostly in terms of bureaucratic
manipulation throughout this whole
endeavor pariston restricted personnel
and made it as difficult as possible for
the extermination mission to succeed and
while the outcome probably would have
been the same either way it seems like
paristan was stacking the deck against
nederer and of course with isaac dead
beyond was now able to initiate his dark
continent expedition which meant that
paristan had no purpose in remaining
with the association so he spent about a
week or so just screwing around with the
election and then then it was back to
business barristan assumed his full-time
role as a sort of vice commander of
beyond's expedition team and we don't
talk about these guys anywhere near
enough but these characters are integral
to the dark continent arc officially all
of them are temp hunters which is
essentially the hunter association
subcontracting then users for jobs that
fully license hunters are either unable
or unwilling to take and as a result
tempunt is generally mocked as being
lower tier and this may very well be the
case for the large majority of them but
this team they are very special as wacky
and wild as many of them appear to be
each of these individuals is an expert
nen user far beyond the scope of your
average fully licensed hunter and beyond
has spent years potentially even decades
gathering this team because each one of
them possess a unique ability designed
to ensure the success of their continent
mission so it's kind of like the nen
equivalent of ocean's eleven if the
casino was a big landmass full of
certain death and the expedition team
actually infiltrated the association as
temp hunters and assisted paristan in
consolidating power within the
association then look when i say
assisted i mean that they were probably
responsible for his various implied
murders which is uh that's a very bad
thing and to jing freaks it was the
closest thing we have to a hero in this
situation i am sorry now of course we
know from the previous arc that jing's
ultimate ambition was to travel to the
dark continent he discovered that beyond
had been planning this expedition even
longer than he and his reaction was uh
well it was mild annoyance he actually
rocked up at bionzler to quote register
a complaint however instead of going
ahead with his planned winch he
immediately asked to join their team now
the reasons why jing had this change of
heart are like amazingly clear because
jing is a very unreliable character when
it comes to things like
like truth but he claims that he's here
to help beyond but also to hinder
paristan jing describes beyond's desires
as a man who wants to adventure and
bring back something fruitful for
humanity whilst he describes paristan as
a man obsessed with perverted
destruction which must be prevented and
half of that is definitely true that in
the past and half however something
within me doesn't accept jing's
characterization of beyond he is far
from a simple optimistic adventurer and
jing knows that however i suppose if
jing were to say that he was here to
hinder beyond then it would be a pretty
rough time gaining the trust of his team
but immediately upon entering jing and
paristan engage in the nen equivalent of
a dick measuring contest with both of
them projecting hostile aura and it's
even implied that jing is invoking the
bloodlust effect and all of this is
contrasted so beautifully by their calm
and collected words but in this moment
jing is more or less declaring war and
paristan even going so far as to say
i'll play with you personally from now
on until you beg me to stop and
furthermore things won't quite be that
simple whilst he has no concept of
paristan's true power jing states that
if paristan were only about brute force
then he just beat the crap out of him
and huh that would be that job done but
if that were to happen then paristan
would only be laughing and that it's his
spirit rather than his body that must be
broken which is a very bane-like
statement to make but all of which is
very dark and unpleasant however jing
does have good reason for feeling this
way because we actually learn a fair
chunk about pariston's character during
the song from paris and himself no less
who states people normally feel
happiness when they love and are loved
in return i feel happiness when people
hate me and i feel compelled to hurt the
things that are dear to me but is that
so strange hmm yes yes it is but that's
why jing can't just beat paristan up
even if it were possible which we don't
know if it is because in that case
paristan wins jinx it comes to hate
which makes pariston succumb to happy
and what we want is paris and sad sad
and broken which is a very classic theme
in hunter hunter more often than not
this series emphasizes mental battles
with physical conflict being used as a
bit of an optional tool for ideological
warfare and as the first move in in the
game thing jing decides that he is going
to use cert paristan's position as
number two now to be fair when it comes
to number twos jing is probably far more
qualified for this position because he
probably smells a bit like [ __ ] to begin
with but to wrestle command from paris
and jing makes a questionable decision
which is to offer the entire team
including paris and double whatever
beyond is paying them and this causes a
lot of controversy amongst the team
because some of them want to take the
money whilst others don't some are
willing to recognize jing as number two
but not take his orders and some just
want to immediately kill jing to prevent
any potential chaos from erupting within
the team due to all of the opposing
thoughts that his presence has spawned
but in the end things do settle down as
jin haphazardly negotiates his way into
the position and probably spends the
annual gdp of a small nation doing so
because these guys these were not cheap
and it's very confusing to many of them
because they can't comprehend why jing
would spend so much to gain so little
and it's more or less because it reduces
the amount of moves paristan has in
their game with less power comes less
options and ideally it makes paristan
easier to read oh and also just to annoy
the crap out of him that that is
priceless because you know we're looking
to break his spirit and stuff as the now
accepted second in command which rather
hilariously beyond the first in command
still knows nothing about jing then goes
on to teach the expedition team about
the dark continent which is something
you'd figure they already know because
it's an emission and all but this
section reveals that beyond has been
less than forthcoming with the true
danger that this mission presents which
isn't something that can be excused by
ignorance beyond is currently one of the
only living people who has actually been
to the dark continent and returned and
he knows exactly what kind of threats
are out there in this effort jing also
reveals the existence of don freak's
author of journey to the new world
although i think that's more for the
benefit of us as readers than it is for
the expedition team however very
excitingly we then get a taste of jing's
nen abilities early on to prevent a
quarrel jing appears to brutally beat a
man until his head implodes in on itself
only for us to snap back to reality and
discover that this had not in fact
actually happened it's a very mysterious
ability with a couple of explanations
the first is that jing projected this
image into the mind of the dude kind of
like how melody can project a beautiful
euphoric garden through the vehicle of
music another is that jing has a similar
ability to sradnik's parallel future
where he can enact an action in one time
stream but either reverse it or branch
off into a parallel time but nobody else
seems to react to this attack so
whatever happened here only jing and the
victim know about jing's next use of nen
was actually a more advanced version of
la aureus remote punch with jin claiming
that he can replicate any attack that
he's been struck with which is important
because a lot of people have a bit of a
misconception that jing's ability is to
copy other hatsu but the explanation
here is that jing he's just such an
absurdly powerful nen genius that all he
needs to do is witness and or experience
a power then he can dissect and
replicate it however that that also may
not quite be the truth because jing then
goes on to use an ability which leorio
did not demonstrate to him which we know
as ultrasound followed by a series of
nine projectiles that jin claims leoria
would use on a much smaller scale as a
doctor to destroy tumors and blood clots
so jing really seems to know a lot about
leorio's powers from that one punch
which gives rise to speculation that
jing's non-ability is a form of analysis
with the condition that the ability is
used on him jing's own power could
dissect the form and function of how an
opponent is using nen which would be an
absolutely insane power because then
combat is all about who can figure out
the intricacies of the other first so
that would make jing pretty to mopey to
emphasize again this is pure speculation
but it seems there is more to jing's
power than just being a gifted or a
genius there are things he knows about
leoria that are a bit of a stretch to
say that he determined from the remote
punch alone but the most interesting
part about the story thread so far are
paristan revealing his feelings towards
jing previously we established that
paristan gains happiness from others
hating him however paristan himself has
never really felt hate towards anyone it
is a completely alien emotion to him
well that is until now this game takes a
very dark turn where paristan starts to
realize that he is noticeably losing and
he calls jing get this annoying which
may not seem like much but paris and he
is not a man who gets annoyed so this is
pretty huge as he even goes on to state
this is annoying we do think alike is
that why i don't like him so annoying i
might grow to hate someone for the first
time in my life i'm looking forward to
this i want to see what i do to someone
i hate again pretty terrifying because
paristan is able to do any number of
horrible things to people that he feels
completely neutral about so what kind of
sickening actions would paristan be
capable of if he was emotionally
invested in the pain and suffering of
another human being harrison again is
just built different built wrong very
very wrong he's more of a monster than
any dark continent creature and zheng
may very well have made a fatal mistake
by deciding to push this man beyond his
limits